wer weiß schon freuen
worden sind
wer weiß schon
morgen sind immer wieder als neubeginn
okay wir sind hier auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt ein sehr gemütlicher ort
in dem man schöne kleine präsente kaufen
kann
sebastian die und dem kinder jack und
das wird super
wir schauen mal dass wir so die boot ist
den riesen
weihnachtsmarkt gibt es viele
weihnachten sie liehen für den
christbaum
schauen wir doch mal was es hier nicht
gibt einen schönen strand hier wollten
wir mal fragen was sie denn da genau für
schöne beine zu kommen haben wahnsinnig
viel arbeit aber wenn man dann in der
ganzen zeit hier beschäftigt ist kann
man dann einfach noch kohle weihnachten
oder ist er ist sehr sehr kalt ich
möchte jetzt einen heißen leckeren
hallo ich habe gern einen über mit einem
glühwein tut gut und werden von inisys
wichtigsten brust auf rettung
herrlich
bewegung
die berühmten herrchen ich auch nicht
ehrlich gesagt da müssen wir zum ersten
mal und wir kommen hier mit fackeln